salut on est aujourd'hui lundi à l'ats
il ya à new york il est 10h 54 il fait
super beau
un très très beau ciel bleu mais fait
moins 4 degrés sakai sa race alors ce
qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui ce que je vous propose c'est
d'aller faire un petit tour du côté de
central park d'aller faire un tour de
patinoire ça fait super longtemps vous
envie d'aller me faire un p'tit coup de
deux patinoires à central park
on va y avoir un peu la nature on va
voir à quoi ça ressemble alors c'est un
petit peu figé c'est l'hiver mais bon je
pense qu'il ya vraiment moyen de se
marrer c'est hyper cool et je vous ferai
ma piaule déjà je trouve un petit hôtel
pas mal pas hyper cher visite de la
piaule alors vous avez c'est moins joli
petit bureau ici alors ici un espèce de
petit scellier pour mettre ses affaires
la grand lit la fenêtre petite salle de
bains cosy c'est toujours moi évier
toilettes baignoire on va faire un tour
à central park
je pense que des choses super cool à
voir on va descendre jusqu'à itam ce
soir là je suis au sud darlene appâte 4
km de central park
times square en dessous puis à prendre
un programme ce qui se passe avant de
partir pour supporter un truc cool par
la fenêtre
regardez ça c'est la vue et vous avez
vous avez une église dans un carrosse
sont dégueulasses un une église juste là
au milieu des buildings frein ni
goulding des fraudes immobilières
de ce côté là c'est bon on y va
[Musique]
pays' hôtel au sud de rennes sur
broadway
c'est pas mal fleuret commandes au
revoir noël à bientôt noël
merci je riais ce afin que fait du bon
boulot au revoir
[Musique]
oh
il fait super froid
le mignon joli but c'est sympathique me
direz vous on va essayer de trouver
maintenant je crois qu'il ya un zoo dans
central park là en hiver il ya la
patinoire est chouette ont des trucs
cool c'est chouette
[Musique]
vous avez des mecs qui courent tous les
côtés ici j'ai pas comment il fait quand
ils font fait hyper froid ouais
qu'aurais je fait pour genève a tiré la
langue jeu j'en serai complètement
incapable mais bon chacun son d'hygiène
de vie mais je pense que je suis
fondamentalement c'est à eux que raison
qui est assez cool aux états unis par
rapport à la france tout est réglementé
ça on s'en doute c'est hyper cadres
aient été réglementé mais par contre ce
qui est faux ce qui est ou ce que
j'arrive plus c'est que les gens vous
suivent énormément les règles font très
attention par exemple dans les bus ne
vous avait pas de contrôleur j'en ai pas
vu en tout cas c'est le chauffeur qui
vont contrôler si vous montez pas si
vous avez pas tiqué je peux vous assurer
que vous montez pas failli
ils sont vraiment en avance à nous par
rapport à tout ce qu'ils aient accès aux
personnes handicapées ça j'ai vu un truc
à las vegas était assez dingue
enfin ça me paraît dingue alors c'est
vrai que la normalité c'est justement ça
qui est dingue pour nous c'est à dire
que vous avez une personne handicapée
qui arrive dans son espèce de flou
roulant automatique comme ils ont ici on
n'a pas trop en france des comme ça on a
mais c'est pas les dames du coup vous
avez la personne qui arrive
le chauffeur tient fram un don qui loue
la plateforme qui les sens en a en
france y descend les gens se lèvent des
banquettes
il relève les banques est le mec rentrer
avec son fauteuil il s'installe le
chauffeur attache avec des sangles de
chaque côté on se tire mon oncle l'accès
extérieur et repas en france vous
verriez un bus le chauffeur va tirer le
frein à main va descendre
et tout ça en plus ce qui est dingue
c'est que les gens ont attendu à
l'extérieur pour pouvoir être contrôlés
par le chauffeur
ce que il s'occupait d'une personne à
mobilité réduite mais ça on voit qu'ils
sont vraiment en avance là-dessus et
nous on sait pas si eux sont en avance
ou alors nous on est à la bourre mais en
attendant j'ai trouvé ça juste top mots
en attendant vous avez à central park
aussi des courts de tennis
ici pas si on voit bien la sakay n'y a
personne qui joue au tennis si on ne
regarde bizarrement comme ça c'est quoi
ce mec qui parle à sa caméra ça c'est un
autre qui est typique aux etats unis
c'est à dire que le fait de bloquer
c'est vachement démocratiser c'est
beaucoup plus connu que chez nous en
france tu te balades alors tu est à
paris mais tu te bats dans d'autres
villes avec ta caméra dire c'est quoi ce
malade mental alors qu'ici ghana comme
quelqu'un qui te regarde mes propres
ça passe inaperçu devant ce ténor mlac
que vous avez beau milieu de central
park
c'est complètement gelé ce
qu'accomplissent forcément ce bail et
dessus mais si vous avez ça circule de
l'eau plus au milieu là bas vous avez le
jet d'eau mais tous les bords là sont
complètement gelé
[Musique]
si leurs spots et à si vous vous avez
tous les joggeurs et courageux qui passe
il veut voir c'est suicidaire cendres je
crois que c'est vraiment on s'aime pas
quand on n'est pas dedans et si le
bonnet aussi c'est vraiment un spot de
d'un mais il ya une vue qui est
magnifique surtout les building derrière
vous n'avez tout derrière le spot est
juste dingue c'est vrai que c'est le
coeur ses poumons c'est l'espace vert au
sein de new york
s'il y avait pas ça et que toute la
pollution on ali se serait rapidement
hier à col today et sa cour et sa cour
et ce à quoi les gens sont courageux
tenir là franchement c'est avec la
lumière sur le lac gelé ses propres la
gueule est derrière vous avez ici ça
c'est juste hop le soleil qui arrivent
dessus c'est le matin rebonds et c'est
un matin d'hiver un camp mais on peut
dire mais il est 11 heures du mat c'est
moi qui fais un peu la feignasse ce
matin c'est incroyable
[Musique]
alors ici on peut bien évidemment faire
de la balançoire et un longtemps que
j'en ai pas fait je crois je suis un peu
rouillée
si on m'avait dit un jour j'irai faire
de la balançoire à centrale pas c'est
que vous étiez complètement fou
comme quoi on peut tout faire dans la
vie même faire de la balançoire à
central park
ici on peut se voir quelques lancers de
balle c'est possible
[Musique]
je veux une écharpe qui posera avec un
petit message je ne suis pas a perdu
j'ai été posées ici pour vous si vous
avez froid au gré des besoins premiers
mois restés au chaud oms student
seminoles de florida comme le parent
coupe laville vous avez forcément de
route en dessous alors aussi pour que
l'état puisse passer parce que la
distance fait quatre kilomètres de long
je vous dis pas trop de bêtises c'est
énorme
vous avez des écureuils de partout s'est
jamais vu autant d curio au mètre carré
pigeon fusion écureuil c'est curieux
pigeons pigeons écureuils ténors en
classe et l'endroit pour faire des
photos
le cube what the fuck que je connais
mais son petit rocher mais derrière in
le panorama de ouf la vue est incroyable
[Musique]
enfin plutôt patinoire maintenant
seulement chez parrot fils max est une
grosse caméra donc ça c'est la rangée il
à mettre derrière dans un casier dans le
film et que l'iphone à ses trousses de
la faire mettre les chaussures
[Musique]
patron perdu cool faire du patin à glace
à central park lâche casser la gueule ça
c'est fait les building derrière le
squat il étouffe rêvé de refaire la
glace c'est génial
[Musique]
auteur du patin à glace central park
je peux dire que c'est fait un coup l'un
c'est mon fils serait mort gelé
expérience ces packs à dos à une fois de
plus ce sont ici lien des cadeaux mais
c'est l'expérience génial par excellence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lancement à nice et rennes c'est
vraiment un truc de fou allez faire du
patin à glace central park
ça c'est fait je conseille ainsi à new
york et vous patinez de vue sur les
building musique de ouf directement à
central park
c'est vraiment complètement complètement
incroyable bon voila un petit peu pour
un retour central park
il ya aussi pas d'autres choses à faire
ici hier un zoo il ya plein plein de
trucs je ne peux pas tout faire
là j'ai très très peu de temps puis jean
marie à tout à l'heure donc voila un
petit peu pour le tour donc j'espère que
ça vous aura plu je vous invite vous
bien sûr à venir à central park par vous
même parce que vraiment le spot est
incroyable que la fin de new york est
vraiment fort venir parce que j'ai tant
de rien voir et des musées de ouf la
ville est dingue
elle vit en permanence est vraiment
vraiment vraiment un monde à part ce que
vous êtes déjà venu au new york vous
avez eu l'occaz un petit peu de venir
faire un petit tour si oui dites nous un
petit peu quels sont les spots qui vous
ont le plus plu si vous avez des
conseils à donner pour aller visiter ce
que vraiment je vais revenir je sais pas
quand probablement l'année prochaine
cette année c'est pas sait pas de quoi
demain est fait donc je reviendrai à new
york
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo merci de
m'avoir suivi surtout mes tripes à on
reste ensemble parce que vous savez que
va y avoir encore énormément de choses
on s'arrête pas là merci à vous
n'oubliez pas vous êtes les meilleurs
je vous invite comme d'hab a laissé des
jolies pousse à vous abonner on reste
connectés et bien je suis une grosse
bise ou moins à bientôt chaos
[Musique]
il